[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good evening.
Welcome.
My name is Hisa Kuriyama.
I'm the Faculty Director for
the Humanities at the Radcliffe
Institute.
And it's my great pleasure to
welcome you and congratulate
you for being here.
This is an event in the
series of the Roosevelt poetry
readings, which is an endowed
event at the Radcliffe
Institute, and an event which
brings poets of recognized
stature to Harvard.
It's an event that was endowed
by a Radcliffe alumni who
was herself a poet.
And in past years,
we've basically
featured one major poet.
But this year, you're in luck.
We have four wonderful poets.
And giving you poetry not
only in English, but also
in French and Italian as well.
It's an event--
I don't know; how many of
you were here last evening?
Were any?
A few of you.
So a few of you got a treat,
a foretaste of today's event.
But today's event is one which
is sponsored in collaboration
with The Fellowship Program
at the Radcliffe Institute.
And along with a wonderful event
which occurred last evening,
which featured our poets--
also some recorded poets--
and a wonderful
musical performance
from a genius composer
from whom you'll
hear in just a few moments.
And one of the themes of both
today's event, as you can see,
and of the concert last night
was the theme of rootedness.
The exploration of the theme
of home, of lost discovery,
finding connections.
And all of which
are related to one
of the major themes
of the Radcliffe
at present, which is the theme
of citizenship and belonging.
So this evening, we have
four wonderful poets.
And I'm going to just
briefly introduce
our biographies in the order
in which they will be speaking.
Our first speaker will be--
or meter reciter--
will be Elisa Biagini,
who lives in Florence after
having taught and studied
in the United States
for several years.
Her poems have been published
in Italian and American reviews
and anthologies, and
she has published
seven poetry collections,
some bilingual, including--
I'm sorry, my Italian
is nonexistent--
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
--and The Guest in the Wood.
Her poems have been translated
into many languages,
and she teaches at NYU Florence.
Our second poet is from
Jamaica, Shara McCallum,
and she is the author
of five books of poetry,
including Madwoman, which
won the 2013 OCM Bocas
Prize for Caribbean Poetry and
the 2018 Sheila Margaret Motton
Book Prize.
Her work has been translated
into several languages
and has led to a Witter
Bynner Fellowship--
I should know this;
Witter Bynner--
from the US Library of Congress,
and a Poetry Fellowship
from the National
Endowment for the Arts.
Shara McCallum is an English
professor at Penn State.
Our third poet is
Irene Gayraud, who
was born in Sete,
(FRENCH ACCENT) France--
France, sorry-- In 1984.
Wow.
OK.
And has published
three books of poetry.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
She has two books forthcoming.
The poetry collection
[SPEAKING FRENCH],,
and her first novel,
which the title is so great.
I really want to read this.
Her study of music has led
her to explore and experience
the relationship between
music and poetry,
and to collaborate
with several composers.
She is an assistant professor
of Comparative Literature
at the Sorbonne.
And our fourth poet--
yes-- is Evie Shockley, who is
the author of semiautomatic,
which was the finalist,
or a finalist,
for the Pulitzer Prize and
the LA Times Book Prize,
and winner of the 2013
Hurston/Wright Legacy Award.
She's published four other
collections of poetry,
including the new black, which
won the Hurston/Wright Legacy
Award in 2012.
A critical study,
Renegade Politics--
Black Aesthetics and
Formal Innovation
in African American Poetry.
And her honors also include the
2015 Stephen Henderson Award,
and the 2012 Holmes
National Poetry Prize.
And she's spending this
academic year as a fellow
here at the Radcliffe
Institute for advanced study.
And she normally teaches
as Professor of English
at Rutgers University,
New Brunswick.
So at this point, I'd like to
welcome the genius composer
from last year-- last evening's
concert, Marta Gentilucci.
One of the things that you'll
notice about all these poems,
and I think these poets--
and I think that was very much
in evidence last evening--
is that in addition to
speaking to this theme
is that they all share
this wonderful musicality.
And so that even if you
don't understand Italian,
or even if you
don't understand, I
think you'll be
able to understand
a lot by the sheer language,
or the sheer communicative
power of the music.
So with that, I'd like to
turn over to Marta Gentilucci.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
So I would pass on the
genius, but I am a composer.
So thank you.
And I would like to say a couple
of words about my research
here at Radcliffe, because I'm
a fellow here, and my work.
So that is the composition of
a canzoniere-- a song cycle.
So looking at the
political and social events
of the recent years,
years of many changes
and displacement of
people all over the globe,
I needed to
re-examine, to question
my own sense of belonging.
My own roots as a person and as
a composer, a female composer.
Then for me, the most
direct way to navigate
these social changes
and these questions
has been to start from
and take to the simple,
and at the same
time, complex fact
that I am a woman
and a composer.
So my research is very
personal, and at the same time,
I hope is not just about me.
Central to the song
cycle, together
with several elements
of my musical research
and my recent work on the
voice, is the exploration
of the feminine
universe's many facets.
The focus is on the experience
of the words seen and perceived
by the female body.
That is one of the reasons
why I decided to work
with female living poets.
I wanted to interact with
the creation of the text.
I want to be fully
connected with the voices
and with the eyes of the
present time, even when it
is uncomfortable, partially
understood, or digested.
In the past month, then, I have
been finding and collecting
material that tells stories of
other women and their songs.
This heterogeneous
corpus of text
will be a part of
my compositions.
In a way, they will be, I
would say, my musical roots.
And the songs will be presented
as an independent sets
of pieces, but in
the future, they
will be performed as
an entire song cycle.
One specific encounter
here at Radcliffe
has been the turning
point for my project.
Evie Shockley, also a
Radcliffe fellow this year.
The discussion we had and her
generosity opened new horizons.
She introduced me to other
American female poets
who she believed could bring
an important contribution
to my project on
roads and belonging.
And they have greatly.
And one of them that is
here is Shara McCallum.
Tonight, here, there is also
the Italian poet Elisa Biagini.
And in a way, she is
also a root for me,
because our work together began
almost, I think, 10 years ago.
And there is also the
new root, Irene Gayraud.
So a French composer
and new encounter.
And in a way, it's connected
to my new home, France.
And to conclude, I
really would like
to say a special thanks
to Sean O'Donnell.
So I did it yesterday and
I want to do it also today
because he has been
really precious.
Because it's thanks
to him that today--
he made it possible
today, four of the poets
that I'm working with are here.
And his curiosity, openness is
listening to my musical ideas.
His vision and trust have been
an invaluable contribution
to my research.
So thank you very much, Sean.
And enjoy the evening.
And we will start
with Elisa Biagini.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
I have very old fashioned
thing to tell me
where I'm supposed to stop.
And I want to--
thanks for being here,
and thank you for
having me here.
It's such an honor to be here.
And to read under a tree is
something that I really like.
It would be fun if we
had a different weather
to actually do it outside.
But not now.
Not at all.
This is traumatic enough.
So yesterday, whoever was here
listened to some fragments
from this series that
I wrote recently,
will be published
in Italy next year
and in the US in a written
journal as well next year,
of this Alternating Current.
That's from Mary
Shelley's diary.
You heard the Italian
yesterday, so you'll
have some handouts there.
You have the English,
but I want to read some
of the fragments in English.
And then a couple of
poems are poems in Italian
so that you get both the--
yesterday was very
much about sound.
Today is about sound, but, you
know, meaning imagery as well.
So in this book, I
kind of investigate
the nature of electricity.
And there are
different characters,
and one is Mary Shelley.
You all know the story, so I
don't have to tell the story.
Think about referring
to such huge figures.
And the idea was this.
Mary Wollstonecraft died after
giving birth to Mary Shelley.
Why not regenerate
who generated you?
So the fragments of Alternating
Current from Mary Shelley's
diary are about her
figuring out the way
how bringing her
mother back to life.
So forget about all
these men doing things.
You know, a doctor
making a man figure.
No.
It's actually her
saying, wait a second.
I've learned a lot.
Let me try this out.
So I will read a few
fragments from these
as if they were taken from
the pages of her diary.
You will excuse my accent.
You have to deal with that.
"A lightning bolt,
a contraction.
Bullet-like rain has been
battering us for days.
The treetops converge
to many electrons here.
Your memory fumes engulfs
like fog to windows.
At a table for hours,
there is a sort
of tremor of plates
around my wrist.
My sleeve is a
curtain for the blood.
Outside, the color
is winter unleashed.
You come back between
clouds and turf.
It is dark like
inside of a crater
as you rise up, a
shadow from my truth.
And on the threshold of my
leap, you acquire weight,
fall onto the center
of the page, open up.
The winds and the
voices, wasps in a jar.
The others crowd around by
the wand, ear, and table,
uncluttered for our encounter.
We are birds fleeing the
cold by heading north
where the wind carries
away saliva and syllables.
They have made it here to
this glass numbed by breath.
I've seen frog's tissue.
A head come back to life.
Where is the electric tongue
that gives voice and gaze
to your melancholic flesh?
In this wide darkness,
I've gathered
dirt in my pockets, electrons
under my fingernails.
You grow larger, embrace
the roots at my years.
To be here is to step
on our own shadows,
even if far off I see the
lava under the claws of earth.
It has the color of cloud
that reflects the gaze
of a knife between two pages.
My eye listens to the
morning fingernail.
And in this nest of nerves,
the wind that wakes me
is the caller of
a rhubarb's talk.
Slow is putting one foot
in front of the other.
At night, in the
forest of [INAUDIBLE],,
it resounds like solar flares
on the surface of the sun.
My synapses sizzle
as the world thins.
Now they are so
thin that they allow
me a seeing as silent as
a bone, and finding you
in the cold glass of the mirror.
Water stays descended
without touching,
leaves counted without
seeing the trees,
glasses clean with carbon paper,
words shaken off my sleeves.
The sky's black and
blue as I gather up
the pieces for your return,
shipment to a foreign country.
Your breath has been kept
in a vase in expectation.
From the blurry threshold,
you come closer.
You up to now without a world.
The shadows are useless, the
light space without walls.
What marvel rises
up to my mind when
I graze the tendon, the
bone of your finger,
the sinew on the windowsill?
The path is made of
husks, fire, bread, milk.
There are words
left in the fire.
The suitors are Braille.
Eyes the distance between
my memory and your breath."
Two more poems, because I want
to take space for the others.
This one is from
this collection,
The Guest in the Wood.
They came out in 2013.
I'll read both the Italian and
English version of the poems.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
"You show me your wounds,
like a soldier, your battle
against another you
consuming your eyes,
bones, skin, who cut
your tendons a while ago,
the cord that holds you,
diver who wants to resurface."
And today, I had the pleasure
to see Emily Dickinson's room.
I'm quite a fanatic.
And the last collection came
out in the US a couple of years
ago.
One section is
dedicated to Emily,
and is now kind of a
member of the family.
Sort of like, you know,
grand-grandmother or something
like that.
Actually, the book in the first
section is about Paul Celan,
and I read some
fragments yesterday.
The central section is about
my grandfather, the third
about Emily Dickinson.
So it is indeed part of
the family at this point.
And the section is called
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]----
"with ink-stained feet
photographs-- a dialogue
with Emily Dickinson."
I basically imagine myself
seated in a corner in her room
in Amherst, even though the
real stuff is here at Harvard.
You know that.
The table, and the chair,
and all the little objects.
And kind of observing
what she was doing.
But when I was done
with this section,
actually, I thought I loved
these two people so much
Paul Celan and Emily Dickinson.
What about having them meet?
Something, obviously,
given they were born
in completely different times.
But who cares?
That's my book, so
I do what I want.
And therefore I have them meet.
So the title is actually
in English, also.
The Italian poem is "Impatient
of the Fewest Words."
and that's taken from
a letter that Susan.
You know, the-- everybody
knows who Susan is in the life
of Emily Dickinson,
I have to say--
and sent to Emily
saying, "you're
impatient of fewest words."
And that really belongs
also to me as well.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
"Standing on the threshold,
my eye in your hand,
your tongue on my ear
so we know one another
by touching each other,
because my eye is grainy
from the strain, your tongue
is still sand-papered.
If the board gives way,
if the voice flounders,
right here in the air is the
word branch that holds us up."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
I'm really honored,
thankful to be here reading
with these wonderful poets.
Marta, thank you for
bringing us all together.
And thanks to everybody--
Sean and everyone at
the Radcliffe Institute
for making this possible.
I'm going to read five
poems, and I'm not
going to say anything
about them because we're
going to have this
great chance to have
a conversation afterward,
other than that I
hope they speak to this theme.
I'll begin with a poem
from the place of my birth
which I've just come back from.
Actually right
before coming here.
"Psalm for Kingston."
If I forget thee, oh Jerusalem.
Psalm 137.
City of Jack Mandora?
Me no choose none.
Of Anancy prevailing
over a mongoose
by the rat, puss, and dog.
Anancy, saved by his wits
in the midst of chaos
and against all odds.
Of all the big boy stories
told by peacock-strutting boys,
hush-hush, but loud enough
to be heard by everyone
passing by the yard.
City of market women at
half way tree with baskets
atop their heads, and planted
in front of their laps,
squatting or standing
with arms akimbo,
su-suing with one another,
clucking their tongues,
calling in voices of pure sugar.
Come, dudu.
See the pretty bag
I have for you.
Then kissing their teeth
when you saunter off.
City of school
children in uniforms
playing dandy shandy and brown
girl in the ring, (SINGING)
tra, la la, la la, (NORMAL
VOICE) eating bun and cheese
and bulla and
mango, juice sticky
and running down their chins,
bodies arced in laughter,
mouths agape, heads thrown back.
City of old men with roomy
eyes, crouched in doorways
on verandas, paring knives
in hand, carving wood pipes
or peeling sugar cane.
Of younger men pushing carts
of oranges and roasted peanuts,
calling out as they walk
the streets and night
draws near; of coconut
vendors with machete in hand.
City where power cuts left
everyone in sudden dark,
where the kerosene lamp's blue
flame wavered on kitchen walls,
where empty bellies
could not be filled.
Where no eggs, no
milk, no beef today,
echoed in shantytowns, around
corners, down alleyways.
City where Marley
sang (SINGING) 'jah
would never give the
power to a bald head'
while the bald heads reigned.
Where my parents chanted
down Babylon, 'fire!
Burn!
Ja!
Rastafari!
Selassie I.' Where they
paid weekly dues saving
for our passages back to
Africa, while in their beds,
my grandparents slept
fitfully, dreaming of America.
City that lives under a
long, memoried sun, where
the gunmen of my
childhood are today's
dons, ruling
neighborhoods as fiefdoms,
where violence and beauty
still lie down together.
City of my birth,
if I forget thee,
who will I be singing the Lord's
song in this strange land?"
"Dear History."
"I could tell when my
parents stopped believing.
Marcus, Marley, Manley.
Their gods deserted
them, leaving
little to wring
between their hands.
After a time,
revolution's light dims.
Ideals get exchanged
for smaller needs.
Milk and bread.
The crumbs of peace.
In the final days,
everyone tried
to explain what had gone wrong.
Politicians said tourists
would no longer come.
Mummy and daddy said
slavery was the root.
Granny said it was the
youth, killing each other,
running wild in the streets.
The night before she and
papa left for America,
I prayed in the dark
of my room, but feared
my words could no longer
spiral up to something beyond.
'We will come back for you.
I promise,' they'd said.
When piece by piece
my family fled,
we didn't see the bargain
being struck to live in a place
where memory becomes
a synonym for home."
"Memory."
"I bruise the way the most
secreted, most tender part
of a thigh exposed
purples then blues.
No spit shine shoes, I'm dirt
you can't wash from your feet.
Wherever you go, know I'm
the wind accosting the trees,
the howling night of your sea.
Try to leave me, I'll
pin you between a rock
and a hard place,
will hunt you even
as you erase your tracks with
the tail ends of your skirt.
You think I am gristle,
begging to be chewed?
No, my love.
I am bone; rather, the sound
bone makes when it snaps.
That ditty lingering
in you like ruin."
Lucea, Jamaica, at the
Hanover Infirmary, 1996."
"What I saw there,
I could not carry.
She lifted a sheet
revealing her abscess.
I was a young woman
then, traveling
towards some notion of home.
But a sheet had been lifted,
and abscess revealed.
I'd hoped I might
meet myself, traveled
home with some notion of finding
the girl I was in braids.
I'd hoped to meet
this younger off
on a coastal road
bridging towns,
but another girl
with braided hair
waved each morning I arrived.
A crossroad between
tourist towns, Lucea,
is a place you could miss.
Arriving each morning, I
thought if I looked enough,
I'd find not an idea,
but the place itself.
Coming to a part of my
country I didn't know,
I looked long to find liquid
pools in opened flesh,
coming to a country
I thought I knew.
A young woman, liquid
and open-fleshed.
I saw there what I
could not carry."
And this is the last
poem I will read,
which is in honor of
Marta, who also once
was a singer as I. "She."
"She could sing the
blue out of water.
She could sing the
meat off a bone.
fire out of burning.
She could sing a
body out of home.
She could sing the eye
out of a hurricane.
She could sing the fox
right out its hole.
She could sing the
devil from the details.
lonely from a soul.
She could sing a
lesson in a yardstick.
She could sing the
duppy out of night.
shoeless out of homesick.
She could sing a
wrong out of a right.
She could sing the
prickle from the nettle.
sorrow out of stone.
She could sing the
tender from the bitter.
never out of gone."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Bonjour.
First of all, I would like
to thank Marta and Sean
for having me here.
It's a great, great pleasure,
and a great honor too.
And then I would also like
to thank Cécile Guédon,
who is here and who
translated the texts you have
on the handout.
And she did really a huge,
huge work to do that.
So I really thank her for that.
I always start with a free verse
poem called [SPEAKING FRENCH],,
which means something like
"The Narrow Hunting Trail."
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
And then I would like to
read four very short prose
poems that are very different.
It's between prose
poetry and flash fiction,
or flash poetical
fiction in a way.
And they are also
translated by Cecile.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
Evening.
I'm so delighted to be here.
I want to just echo
the thanks to Marta,
the appreciation of my
fellow or sister poets,
and thanks to Sean
and Hisa for making
this space available to
us and the hospitality.
Thank you all for coming.
I am going to read three poems.
And two of them are from my
second book, the new black,
which was a lot for
me about belonging
and those kinds of issues.
And this first poem is
from that collection.
It is called "my life as china."
"I was imported.
I was soft in the
hills where they found
me shining in a private dark.
I absorbed fire and became fact.
I was fragile.
I incorporated burnt cattle
bones' powdered remains.
Ashes to ashes.
I was baptized in heat,
fed on destruction.
I was not destroyer,
was not destroyed.
I vitrified.
None of me was the same.
I was many.
How can I say this.
I was domesticated,
trusted, treasured.
I was translucent but not clear.
Put me to your lips.
I will not give.
I will give you what
you have given me."
This next poem is much
newer, more recent.
I spent a semester in Paris
a couple of years ago now.
And I love that city very
much, but I found myself,
as I think many of us
do, looking for a way
to feel at home
in a place where I
was spending nearly six months.
This poem was inspired in part
by that search, you might say,
and by some of the
work of Cy Twombly,
an American-born artist whose
work was being exhibited
at Centre Pompidou that spring.
So there are three
sections to the poem,
and each section is titled after
one of Twombly's paintings.
"ex patria."
50 days at iliam,
shield of achilles.
a mythology begins
with a question
like who are we, where are
we, what is red, why paint,
why me, lord, why?
a person who knows all
the answers can only
borrow a mythology like
i'm king midas or i'm god.
a painter can take a
mythology and remake it
so that it answers a new
question like romare bearden
asking odysseus who are my we?
and cy twombly asking
achilles why are we still you?
painting the eye of
the storm on a shield.
cutting the trickster out
of black and blue paper
and lashing him with glue to
the mast of his last ship.
The journey always rough,
some miserable god under land,
under sea always
looking for company.
people always succumbing.
the hero is the one who
comes home even if it's
by process of elimination.
A playwright can
make a mythology ask
what's wrong with this song?
like suzan-lori parks asking
ulysses about coming home from
the war so why are you a hero
and why are you still coming
home from a war and
women die in wars, too,
even if it's not the
expected death and--
wait that's not a
question but it's still
a mythology if that's the
only thing she knows for sure.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
A mythology can ask why
is autumn so beautiful
and why is winter,
blight-stricken
as it is, so arresting?
a mythology, as opposed
to a young person,
can find autumn and winter
much more striking than summer,
sun-bleached summer, so
legibly the scene of happiness
that nothing else can
really happen there.
A mythology can see
the blood in spring,
the stages of growth a
kind of violence the body
does to itself, it will
never be this way again
and yet it can't get on to
the next moment fast enough.
A mythology can
ask why does spring
throw its arms out
with abandon even
when it's abandoning itself?
a mythology can
ask why is winter
so much greener than spring
even clouded in white?
the icicles trail as far down
the evergreens as they can
but they don't keep the wind
from brushing snow and sun
across the mountain
on the same day.
The inferno is always
burning, men and women
going up in flames.
a poet can ask, why do
daughters grow up by going down?
like rita dove asking
persephone you think he's hot?
[MUFFLED LAUGHTER FROM CROWD]
All the while, autumn is
answering the question
about gorgeous rotting.
just magenta, green,
brown, pink, yellow, red,
violet, flying off the
mythological canvas.
untitled-- a gathering of time.
a mythology of time can
ask a subtle question.
a sky blue can gather white
clouds right before your eyes,
holding them by
threads of paint,
stringing us along so
that we miss the purple.
the thunder is always farther
away than the whitening.
a poet can grab a
mythology of time
that takes place over the dead
bodies of letter after letter.
the tongue lays them to rest
and they cover, are covered by,
a sheet that falls
far from the tree.
a cy twombly can
leave for rome at 29
and still die an
american artist,
a hero who doesn't come home.
A photographer can
snag a mythology
to turn her back on it,
wearing black and steady gazing
from a question that's a
statement of the only thing
she knows for sure
like carrie mae weems
asking institutions
like the british museum
when and where I enter
showing that she's the answer.
contrast, stark.
the steps leading
in leading away.
bright but heavy.
the poet can ask a
mythology a question
like what is black in
the museums of paris?
and again the mythology
pierces the clouds.
it thunders so loud but
so late that by then we've
forgotten we saw the lightning.
we saw the lightning.
we saw it and it
was not subtle."
And I will close
with another poem
from the new black that is
in the form called a ghazal.
It so directly related
to the theme of our event
that I won't say anything
about the content of the poem,
but you should know
that the form the ghazal
is an ancient Persian form.
It's written in couplets, and
what connects the couplets is
a repeating refrain at
the end of each couplet. .
The first line of
the poem tells you
what the refrain is
going to be, and it
locks in at the end
of the second line.
And so after that, at
the end of every couplet,
you know what's coming.
Now the ancient Persian crowds--
and I do mean crowds--
who would come to
poetry readings
would figure out the
refrain and, you know,
sort of shout it along or
say it along with the poet
at the end of the refrain.
I don't know if this audience
is up to that standard.
[LAUGHTER]
But the form invites
it, I want to say.
It's called "where
you are planted."
"he's high as a georgia
pine, my father'd
say, half laughing,
southern trees as measure,
metaphor, highways lined with
kudzu-covered southern trees.
fuchsia, lavender,
white, light pink,
purple; crepe myrtle
bouquets burst open
on sturdy branches
of skin-smooth bark.
my favorite southern trees.
one hundred degrees
in the shade;
we settle into still pools
of humidity moss-dark,
beneath live oaks.
southern heat makes us
grateful for southern trees.
The maples in our front
yard flew in spring
on helicopter wings.
in fall, we splashed
in colored leaves,
but never sought sap from
these southern trees.
frankly, my dear,
that's a magnolia,
i'd tell her, fingering the deep
green, nearly plastic leaves,
amazed how little a
northern girl knows
about southern trees.
I've never forgotten
the charred bitter fruit
of holiday's
poplars, nor will i;
it's part of what makes
me evie; i grew up
in the shadow of
southern trees."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- So this is just the beginning.
I'm sure that we'll
all read these--
I know that I will read
all these wonderful poets,
but also read them
with a new ear.
Having actually heard
the voices I think really
helps us to appreciate
the written word
with new resonances.
So we're going to have a panel
discussion with our poets led
by Professor Lisa New,
who is a Paul M. Cabot
professor of American
Literature here
at Harvard where
she teaches courses
in American literature
from the Puritans
through the present day.
Professor New is the
author of many books.
starting from The
Regenerative Lyric--
Theology and Innovation
in American Poetry to more
recently New England Beyond
Criticism-- a Defense
of America's First Literature.
But she's also active in many
other ways in disseminating
appreciation of poetry.
She's the creator and
host of Poetry in America
and the director of
Verse Video Education.
Since 2013, she has been
producing educational materials
on American poetry
for tens of thousands
of global learners of all ages.
New created Poetry in America,
a public television series
and educational initiative,
to encourage engagement
with American poetry
beyond academic audiences.
Guest interpreters have
included Shaquille O'Neal,
Bono, Cynthia Nixon, Joe Biden,
Herbie Hancock, Elena Kagan,
Robert Pinsky, Sonia Sanchez,
Bill Clinton, John McCain, Liam
Lee, Samantha Power, exonerated
prisoners, clergy members,
pickup basketball players, young
campers at a wildlife preserve,
and many more.
So with that, I'd like
to welcome Professor
New and our wonderful poets.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hello, everyone.
Thank you all for that
beautiful, stimulating, rich
set of readings.
Readings that indeed, as I
heard your voices and the music
in your voices, I
found myself trying
to alter the question I came
in with having just read you.
But I think I'll see
if you alter it for me.
What I found remarkable about
the four of you as poets
is that it seemed like you'd
been kind of conferring;
that you had some of
the same things in mind.
And we can talk in a
moment about if that's so
or why that might be.
Is it our historical moment?
Is it-- what is it?
But I think that the
question it feels
to me that all of your poems
allow us to think about
is, who is an I?
What is an I?
And who is this voice that
travels between places
and may or may not have an
identity or a coherence?
There's a question
that I found myself
asking with this
theme in mind that
had to do with whether
rootedness is the same as
wholeness.
Right?
in all of your poems,
there was a tendency
for things to blow to
smithereens, as we would say;
to fragment, like parts
of a Frankenstein monster,
or like a child detaching
from its mother.
And so I've just thrown
some smithereens out there.
And so here's a
question, and maybe you
could begin to talk among
yourselves and with all of us
with lines of your own
or each others' in mind.
And the question is, is
wholeness or rootedness
or integrity even a value
that you and your own,
each of your poetic
practices, are working toward?
It seems like there is a
story of separation that's
being told with as much
intention and passion
as a story of rootedness.
And I'm wondering-- and I'm
going like this, but not
like this.
But this relationship of the
integral and the put-together
to the rooted and
maybe physical place
is one that I'm
feeling all of you
as poets raising for
us, without being
too pedantic about this issue.
It's a shame to use
a word like issue
after all the music we've heard.
Yes.
Would you--
- Sure, I can begin.
I love what-- thank
you for that question
and for your work for
poetry, by the way.
I like the idea that rootedness
and wholeness are not the same.
And that's at least
partly coming out
of my own experience
of it, which
is I have a great
longing for rootedness.
And at the same time, it's
a dishonest one for me
personally.
And I've seen that
from early in my life,
that fracturing of cells
has been so apparent for me
and made apparent to me by
forces such as migration.
I was even introduced
tonight-- thank you
for your introduction-- as
a Jamaican poet and then
an American poet.
And those are both true, and
they also are not always--
they do not always
make me feel whole.
So I will just
start there and say
there's a lot of reasons
for it in my autobiography.
But then that's made me really
interested in this question
of the self, and
the I, and how we
are trying to make
cohere something that
is at times for
each of us-- mine
are personal to my
racial identity.
You know, my immigration
and national identity.
But I think that's the
sort of position many of us
face that this I is
something we're constantly
trying to make whole.
And also, if we're honest,
recognizing its disintegration
and its propensity
for plurality.
And so I think
that tension for me
is what is most interesting
in art to explore.
In life, I do have to
do grocery shopping.
So I do have to be a
person who pushes a cart.
But in the poem,
I like to expose
the fragments and the ruptures.
And that's interesting
to me-- in the search
for wholeness at the same time.
- When you say pushing a
cart, so many of these poems
are also in motion.
And in motion and
in motions that
aren't necessarily simply the
motion away from a lost home,
but might be other
kinds of motion.
I'm thinking about an arrow.
- Oh, yeah.
- A narrow trail, and
a mythological heroine,
or a sufferer of some kind
who makes their way along.
- Yeah, exactly.
For me, how to be rooted in
the world go through movement.
Like, the body is moving;
following a track or something.
And I totally agree with
this idea of tension,
because for me what I
seek is to participate
in a way in the world.
To be rooted in the world.
And there is big
tension between nature
and very contemporary
and everyday life world.
That's why I'm looking for
images that can be raw,
and mythological, and
these kind of images,
but mixed all the time with very
contemporary and everyday life
images.
That's why, for
example in the poem
I read, there is this image
of a woman who is just sitting
on a tree trunk eaten by
insects, and at the same time,
she just putting her
glass on the table.
So at the same time she
is in the forest in a very
archaic place, and
at the same time
she's in a home using very
everyday life objects.
And for me, these
contracts, this tension
is a way to be participating
in the world in a more
complete way, I would say.
- Where motion--
- With motion, or every
time there is movements.
Like, I get up.
I sit.
I play something.
- And woman don't
get to be the movers.
You know, traditionally.
I mean, you give us a
mythological heroine
with weapons, and--
I think
- But there is
also contrast here,
because she's wearing
weapons, but at the same time,
she's wounded.
- Yes.
- So it's more complicated than
just wearing weapons and being
offensive.
She will never
use these weapons.
She will just at some
point leave them.
In another poem, she
leaves them on the soil,
and they just mixed
with the soil.
And it's a way to be
participating in the world
also.
So she's wounded and
she's wearing weapons.
It's a kind of contrast.
- And you too, Evie
are-- we're coming back--
you too, Evie, are taking us via
Cy Twombly to the mythological.
- Yeah.
I resonate so much with what
Irene was saying about tension
and what Shara was
saying about plurality.
I think that my way of trying
to create a sense of home
in that space of
being abroad and not
seeing the things that
I'm familiar with as even
small signs of home--
it was to gather and
to collect people,
and to see African-American
culture as a myth making
practice, in a sense.
And that I could participate in
that even from away from home,
a home that's
already complicated
as "my life in china" is
meant to indicate as well.
But that sense of being
able to create something
with the fragments, and for
it to be enough at any moment,
and to have to recreate
it at a different moment.
- It's quite
extraordinary thinking
about the that image of
the china that is being
burnt into its strength, right?
Vitrified.
Vitrified?
Is that the-- right.
And the way that resonates
with Irene's description
of a weapon-begirded heroine who
is also wounded and borne down.
And that-- so we've been talking
about tensions, and double,
and doublenesses.
And I was thinking you,
Elisa-- it's very rare
I get to sit with an Elisa who
has the exact same spelling.
[LAUGHTER]
A kinship.
I was, as Evie was talking
about being in Paris,
I was thinking about you
visiting Emily Dickinson's
house in Amherst.
And about-- you both
make visits to artists.
To artists' homes, artists
whose own blown-to-smithereens
tendencies may resonate with.
So would you talk, Elisa,
a little bit maybe about--
- Yeah.
I agree also with what Shara
was saying about the many I's
kind of swarming like bees.
And also true time.
It wasn't just a matter of
space in different locations--
- Many eyes-- I'm sorry--
many I's.
- Yes.
The pronoun I.
- You're right.
The eyes swarming like
bees were really cool, too.
[LAUGHTER]
So OK.
This eye.
- Absolutely.
But also true, history.
So this whole idea that Emily
Dickinson and Paul Celan meet,
and that I'm there with them.
So they're all part of
one huge I-- capital.
[LAUGHTER]
- And I, that is,
the I made out, the I
who goes to make you the poet?
- Yeah, exactly.
Being there.
And also, this idea
of the vertically, I
like it very much.
Looking for the
roots of identity.
You have this one poem.
My grandfather,
his name was Dante.
So obviously, you have--
and I come from
Florence, so you have
to deal with that eventually.
And he worked in--
he was actually a technician,
but he worked in a mine.
So the whole idea of going
down looking for the roots.
So it came.
It wasn't a silver plate.
I could not not write that poem.
It had to be written.
And it's in here.
So that was very interesting.
But then that's my very specific
history of a specific Dante,
a very specific Eliza.
But wait a second.
I'm telling also another story.
I'm telling a story about
looking for specific words.
I'm telling a story.
So it's not just
me is just sharing
this with the kind of search
that every writer does
for the precise term
that we're talking about.
Something being a precise
sound, a precise world.
- And also, the precise place.
I mean, we've been talking
about movement and disintegral
motions.
But all of your poetries, all of
all of your poems that we heard
referred-- almost, anyway--
refer to particular places.
Homelands.
Particular kinds of loss that
we're certainly aware of today,
as the whole world seems to be
on the move with its backpack
and its flu and
its broken bones.
And does-- could we
talk a little bit more
concretely about place?
Because we've been
having a conversation
that's about selfhood
as it's composing itself
and decomposing in a
Frankenstein-y kind of way.
And yet, there are real claims
that home makes on us for truth
telling of various kinds.
- Yeah.
I actually am thinking
right now about--
you mentioned at the beginning
it seemed like we had
conferred, which we hadn't.
But the confluences come
from Marta's project.
And your question makes
me think about some
of our conversations about what
it means for women specifically
to be uprooted or displaced,
and the kinds of things
that we have at our disposal--
sometimes
gender-constrained, but not
ever entirely, right--
but the kinds of things
that we have at our
disposal to recreate home.
And one of those
things is language.
And for me, the poem of
mine that's specifically
about where I'm from--
the south; specifically
Tennessee--
the language in that poetry
is as much the sayings
that we have or
even just the accent
that I can't help
reading it in is so much
a part of what defines
that place as much
as the trees that are the
visual markers of place
that we more
readily think about.
- And those accents come
from outside the self.
They are yours as well, Shara.
- Absolutely.
I couldn't agree more
with Evie's comment
on how language is
a conveyor of place,
particularly when
you leave a place.
And so the things
that are idiomatic
or the expressions that
you continue to hear
mark you as from a particular
geographic space, and even
a temporal space, as
you were commenting on.
Because for example, in
the "Song for Kingston,"
there's a lot of words
I would expect you not
to know what those words mean.
We're reading in English,
the two of us here.
And yet we're reading in
particular kinds of Englishes.
So they are marked by
a sense of rootedness.
And yeah, I think it's
a fascinating thing
to continue to think about how
place is actually real to me,
and also made not
real in the work.
Once you fix it in the poem--
and I don't know
if Evie or others
want to comment on this--
it seems to me
that, for example,
the Jamaica that
I am constructing
in "Song for Kingston,"
that particular Kingston
is a Kingston that doesn't
quite exist anymore.
So I just came back
from Kingston right now.
That Kingston is different
than the Kingston of this poem.
So there's something also
that's desirable for me
as somebody who lost a
homeland to always try
to be reconstructing in memory.
Like "re-membering" the body
that you're putting back
together-- this place,
because I can't go back to it.
And it's sort of
the cliche, right?
Of course we can't go back.
But poetry is this bridge.
And language is this bridge.
- Which has always
lost its referent.
Oh my gosh, I sound like a
French deconstructionist.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's--
- It's (FRENCH ACCENT)
difference, right?
It's endless.
Right.
Yeah.
That's where my French
ends, so I look at you now.
[LAUGHTER]
- I love-- I'm sorry.
I'm so stimulated by this.
You know, maybe it's
my fault. I began
by asking a question about self.
But to be using the
accents that you get,
and the language to
read to us in French,
and in your English
and Italian, we
don't get our accents
from ourselves.
We don't get our
languages from ourselves.
They come-- and they don't
actually come from the ground
either.
They come from
other human beings
who murmur and shoo-shoo.
- Right.
- But that resonate in the body.
The body is the place.
So at least from me,
but I hear it from them
as well, I think the one
element that we have in common--
obviously, Marta
picked us for a reason.
But it could be there is also
an historical moment coming in.
The sense that the fragment--
I mean, since we're
mentioning philosophers,
think about Benjamin, and the
importance of the fragment
to reco--
I give you, present
the fragment,
and I recreate my personal
little story around it.
But then you, with the
very same fragment.
But the common element
obviously is the body.
The way the language
and the sound resonates.
And the need that you have
to make sense of the world
out there.
So the languages is that.
And this is, regardless
of what we write about,
this is really the urgency
that is behind writing these.
And that creates
the space place.
That is, the room.
The page in this specific case.
- I'm thinking Elisa, about
your little postage stamp.
The sit.
Elisa's poems sit on
the corner of the page.
And the space arcs
around them as if--
- Because I want the page
to become the room where
the writer and the reader
meet so that we can share
the space here, the
silence, so that something
new can be created.
- But that longing
and that urgency, too,
is graphically represented on
the page that's just not full.
- Yeah.
Exactly.
- I think it's probably
time to open up
to questions that people have.
Questions.
- Feel obliged to make
a comment because, I
have been named so many times.
And I think it's incredible for
me, because I don't use word,
I use sounds.
But today, for the first
time, I heard all you four.
So the implicit connection
that I make with music,
you made with word.
And so the fact that--
so I see one specific thread
that is really dear to me.
The fact that
movement and fragment.
So the movement is the way in
which you connect the fragment.
The fragmentation.
And the centrifugal movement,
it doesn't create distraction,
but it creates connections.
And so I think this
is what fascinated me.
So also, my music is
made by fragments.
But the need, the urgency,
is to create a whole.
And so what seems to be--
so I agree and disagree
with the fact that rootedness
and whole are not the same.
But at the same time, they
refer to the same root.
And they are participating
through the movement
to the same thing.
So I'm not very good with
words, but I think it's that.
And what fascinated me for
all the poets that are here
is this ability to have this
singularity in the voice.
And I was struck by the fact
that for the first time,
I heard Elisa Biagini saying
her poetry in English.
And I didn't recognized her.
Because for me,
I hear what Chara
was saying that there is
something about identity,
and the identity as Italian
as American-Jamaican,
or a Tennessee, or French.
So I hear that.
And I identify the
sound with this voice
that is not just the
meaning of the words,
but this identity of the sound
that is carried by the voice.
So it was not a question.
It was more like a comet.
But I wanted to integrate
my experience with you.
- Thank you.
- I'm just going to
also make a comment.
- I don't think this
is either on so--
- Can you hear me?
- Come more close.
Yes.
Much better.
- As a biologist, and when
you're talking about rootedness
versus wholeness,
I was thinking,
well, a route starts
as a single trajectory.
But then, of course, it becomes
diverse, and actually becomes
even larger than the crown.
And I think that's in some ways,
that kind of encompasses what
to me a lot of your poems--
which were all beautiful,
and thank you so much--
we're saying to me.
I just wanted to say that.
- It's hard to ask
questions about poems.
- This is daunting.
It's a somewhat set of
theoretical concepts
we've been talking
about, so I can imagine
it would be a little daunting.
Yes, please.
- I have a pretty big voice,
so I'll try it from here.
Can everyone hear?
- Mm-hmm.
- Good.
I was intrigued by vitrification
through glass, mirror, windows.
Almost each one of you had
some reference to one of those.
Glass vitrification.
Maybe you could talk a
little bit about that.
How [INAUDIBLE].
- For me, I mean, the image
of glass or verification
has something to do with the
impossibility of being totally
in the world.
Like, something is resisting.
You can see everything.
You can almost touch everything.
But there is kind of borders
that you cannot totally cross.
So I would say this is
why this image comes--
actually, it comes very
often in my poetry.
Not that much in the
texts I read today,
but in my other texts
it's almost everywhere.
So that's a nice question
because it's really
something important for me.
- The metaphor of china--
so not exactly glass, but it--
I forget how I stumbled
onto it, although it just
feels like one of those
gifts from the universe.
But what made it
really powerful to work
with for me is the idea that
it's both fragile and strong.
You can have something
glass or vitrified,
a material like china
for hundreds of years.
Or you can-- one false
move, and it's gone.
And that kind of tension
is something that
drew me to it in that poem.
- To me, yeah.
I agree on the image of
specifically of the glass.
And to me, it's also very much
connected with the precision
we're talking about.
With the clarity of
vision; the precise word.
Few words, but very precise.
The kind of light that you get,
for example, with this weather.
So sharp with the snow.
Yes, I'm cold.
I'm insisting that-- no,
but it is very important.
I come from the country--
but now we are all experienced
in traumatic things
politics-wise--
where there is a lot
of talking, a lot of
talking, and it sounds like.
And then, oh, no.
You didn't understand me.
I meant something else.
Like, no.
Words should be precise.
If you are a writer,
you have responsibility.
Therefore, write-- and even
more if you're a politician.
So I want precision, clarity.
Few words, but just with weight.
- I wish I had something
to add, but I'm
unaware of this
image in my work.
So I'm sitting here and I
listen to what they've said,
and I think, that
sounds brilliant.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
- But these are also all images
of a fearsome kind of strength.
- Yes.
- I'm a little bit afraid
to drink from that tea cup.
[LAUGHTER]
And those honed weapons.
And a militant kind of
clarity that I do think
has something to
do with the fact
that we have four women
poets at this moment
writing poems that want to
be balanced on a knife edge,
and don't want to
be doctrinaire,
and don't want to oversimplify.
Thank you very much.
As you say, Elisa,
the public discourse
is so full of both
mush and simplification
that there is a great
rigor that you all
seem to be striving for,
both by giving us heroines
of rigor and images of--
that have the sharpness
of Boston weather.
Those of us, we embrace it.
Yes, please.
- Thank you so much
for your readings.
It's such a pleasure
to listen to you read
and to hear your voices embody
the works that you've written.
My question is actually
about listening,
because I always think that
the difference between artists
like you and someone like
me who is not an artist
is that you have a secret
about how to listen.
And I wonder if you could talk--
this is a far less
erudite question.
It's a craft question.
I wonder if you
could talk about what
you listen to find your poetry.
Thank you.
- I can start.
Thank you for that question.
I think it's actually
quite erudite.
I think it's a complex one,
sound, to try to parse,
and why you follow the
language you follow as a poet.
I trust my ear.
And I trust the ear
that actually speaks,
that hears what we speak
or any sounds in the world,
as well as the ear
that's in my mind.
So I think of those
as two different ways
that I write poems.
And but yes.
I mentioned the
last poem that Marta
had told me she was the
singer once, as I was.
And I think that that's
why when I'm writing poems,
I'm also really
attentive to silence too.
Not just the words,
but how much silence
there has to be for
those words to carry
the kind of power and weight
that they need to carry.
And so all of that is
my response that when
I'm listening,
I'm trying to hear
all the different possible
silences as well as sounds.
- Go ahead.
- OK.
Yeah.
So thank you for this
question, because I
would say my way to connect
to the world is mostly by ear.
So I listen everything,
everywhere, all the time.
Every sound, every voice.
And I love languages and
listen to different languages.
And I try to focus on
sounds like, for example,
sounds of the nature
like in my poems.
But also, for example, I
enjoy so much the subway sound
in Paris, for example.
It's extremely interesting.
Yeah.
Marta can tell it's
very-- lots of harmonics.
Many interesting things.
And I listen a lot, music.
Lots of kinds of music.
And it's really feeding
me every day to write.
So classical music, but also
jazz, and rock, and even pop
music.
And yeah.
And I totally agree with what
you are saying about silence.
It's not often you can
listen to the silence.
It's very rare.
But in some places,
you have the chance
to hear sometimes
almost silence.
Almost.
And it helps also
a lot to find how
to settle a word into
the void; the void
or the emptiness of the page.
- I would add to the
things that we listen to
or that I listen to
that inform my poetry--
so all of those things,
but also commercials.
And just the most
degraded language
can become interesting when
you find a way to bring it
into a different context.
So that's one thing.
And I also think--
I mean, you also kind of
asked about how to listen.
And I don't know if you
were here last night,
but one of the poets who's
not present but is also
participating in
Marta's project--
Solmaz Sharif-- she
has a poem that played
in which she has these lines.
"I'm not sad.
I'm not sad."
And I'm bringing them
up to say that sometimes
what you have to listen for is
the information in the tone,
even if it's cutting
against the information,
the semantic information
of the words.
And to just use your own
emotional intelligence
when you're listening.
- I totally share
all their visions.
I want to try to answer
with a short poem, if I may.
- Please.
- This comes from the
Paul Celan section,
so it has one line by him.
"We speak darkness
that sticks to breath.
We speak glass that
makes holes in paper.
Listen with your mouth.
Look in the mirror
with your ear."
- That's dangerous.
- Also thank you.
This is an incredible pleasure.
I am recalling from the
question of how do you listen--
oh, hi.
I'm recalling a snippet that I
heard when the poet Elizabeth
Alexander was being interviewed
by Krista Tippett, who
is a radio host.
And Elizabeth Alexander
was telling over
the story of the rehearsal
for her reading a poem
at Barack Obama's inauguration.
But that was the next day.
That day, she was just
practicing and popped off
a poem that she knew
very deeply by Gwendolyn
Brooks about onion frying in the
kitchen, and a set of things.
"kitchenette building."
- Mm-hmm.
- Yes.
- And Elizabeth
Alexander described
that she's just sharing this
poem that had become something
she knew so well.
And at the end of
it, she realized
that the random
people in the mall
had all stopped and
listened, and were clapping
And so my question
for you is, has there
been an incredibly
powerful moment where
you have read poetry?
[LAUGHTER]
- It's a good question.
This one.
- And the mic was on.
It was that kind of rehearsal.
- It was one of those,
like, [INAUDIBLE]..
And she described it as it
was people who were just
going about their day.
But it transformed [INAUDIBLE].
- I'm sure every day.
- Oh, yeah.
We write inaugural poems often.
It's hard to answer
that question.
I mean, I actually really
love reciting poems to people
that I've memorized
other people's poems.
So for me, there's a really
great pleasure in doing that.
And one that's coming to mind,
of course, is Elizabeth's.
So I would say as
much as anything,
I get great satisfaction and
joy out of sharing poetry.
Yeah.
Probably though, in terms of a
sort of transformative reading
for me, I would have to say the
first time I read in Jamaica.
And a very unusual
series of events
occurred in which I reconnected
with my father's family
after not having known
them for 20 years.
So that poetry could do that
was phenomenal in my life.
But I don't know if
that's about the reading
or it's about just the
coincidences of time.
- If I may.
Mine wasn't actually a reading.
I do also installation
projects with my poems.
And this one, I'd
asked a bunch of people
to tell me about themselves
through an object.
And I wrote it, the
poem, on a pillowcase.
And then I hang the pillowcase
outside their windows.
So people during
this small festival
were given a little map.
So they walk around
this area of Florence,
look up, and read the poem.
It would be very nice,
because they didn't know me.
So I could just walk
around and listen
to what they were saying.
And that was great because
the people were saying, oh.
I like it.
It's poetry.
I usually don't like poetry.
But this, I like it.
You know?
And kind of surprised.
So that was very
nice, because it
wasn't the usual crowd of
people that came for your book
and such and such.
It was complete unexpected.
People went to get
their bread, whatever.
And so, walk the
dog, and like, oh.
There's a poem up there.
You know?
And that was very nice to
hide and listen to that.
- Yeah.
You set a really high
bar with your anecdote.
[LAUGHTER]
So nothing like that.
But I think I feel like I
have a lot of powerful moments
with poetry being shared.
That's kind of a through
line in a low bar sense.
One that comes to mind
from recent memory--
this is actually
another Paris story.
I read at the American
University there.
And there's a poem I wrote
I think most immediately
in the aftermath of the
Orlando Pulse shooting,
but that drew upon a
visit to a detention
center in [INAUDIBLE],, just
outside of [INAUDIBLE]..
And brought that all the
way through a kind of global
look at places that become,
where their very names become
sort of metonyms for violence.
Particular violent acts.
And I've gotten
emotional reading before,
but it was the most, I think,
present, the most clear moment
when I think
everyone in the room
was just in that same space.
And that kind of collective
experience is one of the things
that I think poetry's great at.
- For me, I would say to connect
with what you were saying,
it was also after the
terrorist attacks in Paris.
And I was really
feeling very bad.
And when I'm feeling bad, I
just recite to myself poems.
I know lots of poems.
And I just think about texts.
And I thought, OK.
I will have to go
teach tomorrow.
And what can I do
with my students
to discuss what happened and
to comfort them in a way?
And I said, OK.
What I would do
is to read poetry.
So I search in all my books
authors that I would think
could help my students.
And I choose poems.
And I made a handout of maybe 10
poems that I found very strong.
And then in the class, we
discussed what happened,
and we read these poems.
And it was just so strong
and so intense to share this.
And many of the
students were crying.
And they told me then
that he helped a lot,
because there were
poems speaking
about violence, and
political violence,
and all these kind of themes.
So I think this was
the most intense moment
I had with poetry.
- So let me take
me the opportunity
first to thank everybody.
I'm going to ask one more
question, one last question.
But afterwards, there is
a sort of modest reception
where we can continue
our conversations.
So I'd like to everybody to
linger and speak individually
with our guests.
The question I have is a
follow up one on question
that was just asked, and
it's about your experience
performing your poetry.
So you write poetry, presumably,
in some sort of isolated ,
space and personal space.
And you imagine a reader.
You imagine your
connection to other people
is through reading.
This is the most primal form.
And then there
might be something
in between that and the
kind of experience which
was just mentioned, where
you might be performing
in a formal setting.
The kind of setting
where you're reciting,
but it's not necessarily
a formal setting,
but people happen to be there.
And then maybe some of you had
also the experience of reciting
on radio, and how the
differences in your connection,
direct connection to audiences,
shapes your reading of poetry.
How you perform it.
Or whether you find yourself
looking at the audience
and then reading the same
poem in a different way,
just by looking at the
people who are there.
- I am the designated beginner.
[LAUGHTER]
I start answering the questions.
Yeah, I think that's
a great question.
And thank you for
having us here.
I don't write poems
with anybody in mind.
So I do write them by myself.
I write them to the dead, often.
Or to the poem.
That's who I kind of think about
when I'm writing, I suppose,
if I'm thinking about
anything other than syntax.
So that's the truth.
But then when I'm in front of
people, and as I am right now,
I love people, and I
love to look at people,
and see them, and try
to have a connection.
So that's what I try to do
then when I read the poem.
I try to find the people
I'm reading to connect.
But your question really makes
me think about last night
more so than radio.
I've done that as well.
And then you think it's a
disembodied sort of person
you're trying to find, right?
But Marta's-- you know,
what helped me a lot was,
Marta was our director.
We had rehearsals.
This was very exciting for
me, because I don't usually
get rehearsals as a poet.
And we had our
director, our composer,
who said something I thought
was exceedingly helpful,
which was to project outward.
And so I think that maybe
is the truest thing I could
say that cuts across this.
When I'm writing the poem,
I'm projecting inward.
But then when I am giving
a reading or a performance,
to varying degrees, what I'm
doing is projecting outward.
So thank you, Marta,
also for that,
because it helps to answer
this great question.
- I have a-- may I jump in?
So I now produce
television shows on poetry.
And I'm fascinated by what
a resonant space the 24
minutes that used to hold
situation comedies or the news,
what a very resonant space
24 minutes is for a poem.
The resonance and the
tackiness does not
come from the delivery outward
from a poet to an audience.
And I think about that a lot.
I think about this
form and format,
which is an ancient one.
We deliver.
The poet stands at the center
and delivers of herself.
And I confess that I am
ambivalent about that form,
that format, especially with
this, and this, and this.
Sorry, Radcliffe.
Seems like gift
horse in the mouth.
But is-- we have grown very,
very accustomed to thinking
what we should do with a
poem is look at the poet
and watch the poet read it.
For the larger
understanding of poetry,
I'm glad that there's TV.
I can't believe I'm
saying that, but--
and radio.
And I think we're
learning from how
we're all addicted
to podcasts how we
want to live just in our ears.
This collective experience
has an importance we don't we
don't want to give up.
But for-- I don't know.
There's something about TV that
to me is like chamber music.
You know?
It's like a very small recital
hall that works really well
for poetry.
I try to try to make it work.
And it's so different
than the internal looking
and the giving.
Evie and I have filmed
together for television,
so we'll see what happens.
- Yeah.
The evidence, the outcome
is still yet to be seen.
It's so funny.
I hear and resonate with
what both of you have said.
But I guess since
I've been called,
I'll just say that I'm very much
thinking about audience when
I write.
I am writing to you all.
There are the you
all that I know,
and the you all that I know
will get all of my references.
And then the you all
that I'm wondering, OK.
Are they going to go
to Google for this?
How can I make them
want to Google it?
You know, I'm very much
wondering what somebody
is going to do with it.
It's very much-- and I say that
as someone who doesn't, even I
read a lot of I poems--
I am from the south
and so forth--
that's not always the
mode that I'm writing in.
But I love to think
about audience.
And I do think that
maybe the takeaway for me
is that all of these
different ways--
you can't get a
poem in a bad way.
Tracy K. Smith, our
current poet laureate,
has a podcast now where she's
doing, like, five minutes--
it's called The Slow Down--
five minutes, one poem
and her little
introduction of it.
And every day, it
just downloads,
and you can just listen.
And it's got jazz
in the background.
And it's just this, like,
escape from the world.
The kind of shows
that Elisa puts on
are these gatherings, and
layers, and sort of webs--
I was saying this earlier-- webs
of reaction to a single poem.
This space where we are live--
I love to watch
theater, and so I'm
very much into the energy
I give you all from myself.
And take-- I draw on you.
If you sit there and are quiet
and don't say "southern trees,"
it matters.
[LAUGHTER] It
affects the reading.
So yeah.
Just all of those.
Thank you for just raising
that as a question.
- Yeah.
Great question.
- I think it depends, also.
Because at times-- for example,
for the Emily Dickinson,
I had her in mind.
So I was physically writing
these things thinking, OK.
Then I'm leave this
poem on her bed,
and let's see what you're
going to think about it.
And so same thing with
Celan in this case
was this dialogue with him.
And then obviously,
they embody the other.
- That's such an
important point,
that poets are talking
to their predecessors.
They're talking to the
language that came before them.
- Exactly.
And they go back through
that language, right?
And they come the others.
So it's the, once again,
everybody and the nobody
that we know she said she was.
So it kind of shifts and moves.
So once again, it's the fragment
that needs to be recomposed.
- I would say that I don't
write for the audience.
But as I write by ear,
I pronounce the texts
even if I'm alone
in my room, and--
even more if I'm
alone in my room.
I pronounce the
texts with loud voice
and to try to experience
what you will experience.
And what I love is then to
be surprised by the reactions
of the audience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you all.
I think we're supposed
to drink wine now.
- Is there wine?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]